بعد الاستقرار في منزل صغير في اليمن لمده
عشر سنوات اصبح اللاجئ السوري محمد كاشف
عائلته مشردين مره اخرى
ويعيشون في خيمته بحديقه عامه
لا يملك محمد غير بعض المؤن وموقد على
الحطب لتدفئه اسرته في ليالي الشتاء
البارده عائله محمد واحده من الاف عائلات
سوريه اللاجئه في تركيا
وجدت نفسها بلا ماوى بعد الزلزال وتعيش
الان في اراضي عامه في برد الشتاء تنتظر
المساعدات والفرج
وبعد ما صارت الهزه وطلعنا لهون حسينا
حسينا في البيت
وبالعيش اللي كنا باركين فيها يعني يعني
ايش بدي احكي لك يعني وضع وضع كتير كتير
صعب وما حسينا بالبيت الا لبعد ما فعلنا
البيت
على الجانب الاخر من الحدود الفاجعه امر
والفقد اكبر
سلقين وحارم وجنديرس والاسارب بلدات سوريه
محاذيه لتركيا كانت الاكثر تضررا بشريا
وماديا الوضع مساوي جدا الوضع ماساوي جدا
انا ما بحكي على ناحيه بس وناحيه الحاره
اللي انا ساكن فيه على شكل ضمن عموما
منطقه جنديرس ضمن المدينه الشكل الماساوي
انضم نازحون بسبب الزلزال الى ملايين من
سكان المخيمات بعد ان تهدمت منازلهم
بكارثه اخرى ليس للبشريه فيها اضحى حلم
كثير من العائلات في هذه المناطق محصورا
في ايجاد الخيام لاوائهم من ليالي الشتاء
الطويله البارده
لجانا لمخيم يعني بحيث انه مخيم بس دروي
ما اكثر
وبعدين يعني شلون بدي اقول لك من قلت
الماده يعني الواحد مثلا يجيب قنينه مي لا
عنا مصاري الا عنا لباس لا عنا شيء ما
عندنا غير رحمه رب العالمين
تسبب الزلزال بترك اسر كثيره تكافح وحدها
وتطركها
عبر عشرات من السكان ورجال انقاذ عن قله
حيلتهم اذا انقص المياه والغذاء والادويه
والمعدات
لمواجهه اثار الكارثه وامام قله الدعم
الدولي
هببوا تطوعون لاحداد وجبات طعام ساخنه
وتوزيعها على المخيمات التي تؤوي مشرد
زلزال
معلمنا ومهندسون وطلبه جميعهم في خندق
واحد تلبيه لواجب التضامن الانساني